hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
and I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch
the trailer for Disney's a wrinkled
Winkle Dingell and time religion time
eater Dinklage in time John are you
ready I am prepared for Oprah you read
the book I read the book years in your
head Mayer CGI more than most that's the
key we were seen next to the disaster
artist
[Music]
straightline is not the shortest
distance between two points what I'm so
confused has two kids moving it's it's
pretty sci-fi
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is you do I do it girl save the day
I can't slow that run closed
you don't like a
Wow apprehensive crawling this looks
beautiful
it does look pretty beautiful
[Music]
there's Michael Payton his name they
just showed him
[Music]
sweet diggity is pretty dazzling trailer
Chris Pine is taking it the most serious
set of everyone yeah trailer man
everyone is in a Disney movie except for
Chris Pontius of his body maybe he's
only gonna be in a couple scenes and he
felt the need to really release it
laughs and now I'm just gonna play back
her little thing about science
I've heard that clip twice now and I'm
still a little lost she's explaining how
this this fifth dimensional travel works
I heard double toast to talk about this
earlier and they brought this point up
that other shows and other movies have
used like the paper theory to explain
this or they'll be like take a piece of
paper what if you fold it and you poke a
hole of it yeah it is that but with the
string and in an ant it's basically
going like if you fold the straight line
of time then you can just go from one
point to the other it's a very very very
very very simple illustration
interdimensional travel they teleport
from between realms well I'm hoping when
I'm watching the actual movie I'm not
sitting there worried for the kids I'll
care less about my price of admission
and more concerned about our kids well
what's going on well they're very
confusing me as I remember the book it's
a pretty out there and pretty
imaginative you know story and the thing
about these is that you know in a book
format it works differently because yeah
seeing some of this stuff come to life
you are like this looks intense that
looks like there will be peril there
will be fight and you know vigor yeah it
looks like yeah I'd be a little bit
intense but it also looks pretty
gorgeous and something about the casting
to me is kind of a turn-off like when
you get like big actors to fill in roles
for marketing purposes like no one looks
like they're doing something that's like
I can see why they got Reese Witherspoon
here I could see why they got Mindy
Kaling here I mean Oprah seems like a
little bit more of why I get like and
gather why they might have got her Oprah
as being this like inspirational
motivational type of speaker she's an
elder stateswoman of life I guess I see
where you're coming from I feel like
there's an instinct to do that a lot of
you do that a lot around children so we
gotta pack that supporting adults yeah
we probably don't have to pay them as
much because they won't shoot as many
days these kids are you do like the
Alice in Wonderland films where it's
about Alice but no one knows that
actresses so you surround her with a
bunch of big actors who are like you
just show up and do a thing which
celebrity are you going to spend the
next ten minutes kind of the vibe I'm
getting with this other than that one
thing I feel like this will probably be
a really enjoyable film
I feel like stranger things has been a
large
contribution to the resurgence of life
watching kids of adventures and like
dangerous peril situations has a helping
hand for sure it's nice to see a
live-action Disney movie that's about
children having a deal with saving the
frickin world or something I think Alice
in Wonderland is actually a pretty good
touchstone in talking about this because
my fears are that this movie will kind
of become that because you know it's
very fantastical and there is a lot of
CGI and there is a lot of you know like
you were point out earlier big-name
actors and stuff so I can see how a lot
of things could go wrong I do think it
they're using their effects and their
resources to make you sing great yes
scenes and scenarios that yeah are
mind-bending and I feel like that's part
of where that stuff works the best name
yeah oh absolutely you could tell when
there's real actors and obviously you
can tell that CGI in green screen but
it's believable enough for me where I
imagine I'm in the moment of the film
I'm not gonna be looks like I'm sure
I'll be able to buy the situation I hope
because that's that's part of the
problem with Alice in Wonderland for me
is after a while I was like the same way
that like if you eat too much sugar it
starts to hurt your teeth the CG starts
to separate from the image in my eyes
start to hurt looks like they also threw
down for some really good production
design like the costumes look great I
can't tell which backdrops are real and
what not but but I feel like the costume
design looks very real as opposed to
watching a bunch of CGI characters yeah
which I'm really happy to see cuz even
like no akyuu first google i nodi season
a lot more live-action movies where do
you see like even Johnny Depp is the Mad
Hatter of some of him is like CGI yeah
like I don't see that with the human
beings here which I'm glad like Oh Chuck
I'll finish this looks like Zach
Galifianakis yeah I'm cautiously
optimistic about this I think her name
is really sharp and I think it's cool to
see her tackle a giant property based on
a beloved book like this you know I
think that's a cool step and if we know
Disney Disney allows you to have
creative control if you're the director
and to just do what you want to do most
definitely 100% what they're especially
knows honestly the only one I skipped
down on was absolutely lookingglass I
for the most part enjoyed Alice in
Wonderland I enjoyed all the other
live-action one so there's nothing here
really swaying me
I'm not gonna like this film I'm pretty
sure I'll walk out going I enjoyed it I
might just chew it up and forget about
it over the weekend but that's the
overall I I feel like I'll just enjoy
the time it'll be a good family film for
people to see but who knows maybe it'll
be more monumental and more impactful
than I'm getting from the impressions of
the trailer really deliver on you know
the story is really gonna deliver and
become a classic like the book is you
know who subscribe to the real rejects
people click that notification bell you
can follow us on social media do it and
if you're down for it become a patronage
ected a community over there on patreon
was has been growing a lot in the past
couple days like 20 new people came over
we make daily post over on our patreon
try to stay in touch we reply back there
yada yada yada so go follow the snares
later